joined today by dr. Karen DeSalvo who
has practiced medicine for 20 years in
Louisiana and most recently served as
health commissioner in New Orleans and
then as acting assistant secretary for
health in the Obama administration until
January of 2017 it's so great to talk to
you you know we've been following the
various iterations of Republican
attempts to repeat a repeal and replace
the Affordable Care Act
each worse than the previous in some
ways with some marginal improvements
depending on where you look from a sort
of 30,000 foot perspective at this point
what do you think is the fundamental
problem with the approach that
Republicans are taking to these bills
it's hard to me that state 30,000 feet
cannot be honest with you all I can see
are the faces of the patients that I
took care of over the years who are
uninsured and who now I know are going
to have to struggle again go to bed
worried that they're not going to be
able to get the medicine they need or to
have some bankruptcy issues I mean this
is also not just about the end in short
but I think the fundamental challenge
that we're facing with this new approach
is that it touches everybody in this
country in some way it stands to reverse
some tremendous progress that we've made
in last eight years to see that people
have access to affordable health
insurance which gives them access to
care and then health and so it's a
pretty big step backwards one of the the
approaches I've taken is that if you
start with Obamacare which is really no
progressive panacea right I mean we're
talking about particularly when we talk
about the the individual mandate this is
something that was proposed by a
conservative think tank during the 1990s
there's nothing socialistic in any way
of mandating that tens of millions of
people buy products from for-profit
companies when you start with that and
then you look at the promises that were
made by the current president of it's
going to cost less no one will lose
coverage and quality of care won't go
down it's just sort of impossible right
I mean there's there's really no way
that you can take Obama care which is
already not as I said far to the left
and go further right and do those things
that the
said can be done somewhere someone's
either going to have to pay more or have
fewer benefits or have a lack of access
it from a mathematical standpoint am I
missing something there well you know
you're exactly right the Affordable Care
Act proposal 1 was built upon principles
that were considered to be an inter
middle-of-the-road to build on the
capitalist system that we had of private
insurance and the private sector being
able to deliver care as well as for
shoring up the safety net and over time
to get people to have independence
financially to be able to shop for their
care so they have their own insurance
product that would allow competition in
the marketplace from from the delivery
system so a lot of free-market
principles built in but then a
recognition that for a variety of
reasons that health insurance is unabled
for many people and we have to be
attentive to this idea that people walk
into the insurance marketplace with
pre-existing conditions I think there's
also an interesting part about the
Affordable Care Act that a lot of people
forget which is it freed people from
needing to have employer-sponsored
insurance or stranded freed young people
up to the age of 26 need to be able to
have coverage so it changed not just the
way we provided care for low income
people changed the way all of us receive
insurance about you know pre-existing
conditions and the affordability of the
products or the way that that we can
anticipate those going to cover mental
health screening prevention and and so
all that of course was expected to cost
more and honestly it was moving along
the pathway as the budgetary
expectations were wasn't bringing more
people into the system but even within
with bringing more people into the
system the Affordable Care Act was able
to bend the cost curve in this is really
important because what we were able to
do and still are is to see that care is
not just available to more people but
it's more efficient and this is this
discussion about polling coverage from
people distracts from that opportunity
to actually make care more
person-centered and more efficient more
efficient for people because at the end
of the day we all agree I think that we
need to be more thoughtful about how
much care cost it doesn't mean we can we
should do that by taking it away from
people we should just make it more
efficient yeah and there's some broader
conversations there
in terms of should-should health
insurance companies if we're going to
have the type of system that we have
which I don't believe is the best system
but if we're going to have it should
there be health insurance reimbursements
for outcomes or for each procedure and
test and thing that is done by a care
provider that's sort of a different
conversation one thing I do want want to
ask you because of of the work that
you're doing now I in my mind have this
initial reaction when I hear twenty two
million people are going to lose
coverage even if we take out the ones
that will sort of lose it because they
don't want it right some people will no
longer be forced to buy insurance and
will choose not to but if we forget
about that we forget about those who
will be priced out because of the
increased cost if you have pre-existing
conditions or for all of the other
reasons do they in your mind understand
why that would happen in other words
will there be political repercussions to
those who repeal and replace Obamacare
or will it just be blamed on Democrats
as Republicans and Donald Trump have
tried to do for months now will will
there be a price to pay I guess is what
I'm asking if indeed millions of people
lose coverage so two things on that and
one is that the price to pay clearly is
in the health of people so no matter the
political repercussions as a doctor as
somebody who has been in this space for
a long time the data is pretty clear
that health insurance saves lives and it
reduces suffering that there is going to
be suffering and people probably are
going to lose their life if they don't
have health insurance coverage and
that's not I think the second piece of
this that folks forget is that most of
the people who have benefited from what
happened under the Affordable Care Act
from an insurance standpoint are people
who are working people who are working
poor in particular that have no no way
to exit access to health insurance
coverage and make too much even to be
eligible in many states for Medicaid and
maybe I just add a third thing as we
keep getting hung up on this 22 million
number and they're very importantly
people they're going to be you know our
patients and our neighbors and our
family who are going to lose
access to coverage but the kinds of
changes that are being thought about
have repercussions that will touch
everybody in this country so you know
remember that for example more than half
of nursing home care is paid for by the
Medicaid program that half of the babies
in this country are born into into the
Medicaid program so this is not a small
proportion of our population that would
be that would be impacted if we make
these kinds of financial choices in
front of health choices and I would just
really like the conversation to stay
focused on what this means for the
health and well-being of our communities
and the people that we know and love in
our communities including for
documenting our patients are you of the
mindset that the employer connected
for-profit health insurance paradigm
that we have can be quote fixed in a way
that really works well or do we need to
be looking at other systems altogether
like most of our other developed country
counterparts have now I'll actually
point to the American Medical
Association who in their recent Congress
added a need to look at other models of
financing health care including
single-payer systems so even kind of
traditionally conservative physician
groups are starting to say maybe we
should at least look at the option the
reality is is that we have a private pay
system by large that has some overlap
with a public pay system it's worked
mostly it's been working increasingly
better for the last eight years as more
people have been brought into the system
so I frankly would rather see us in the
short run fix what's wrong with the
current system that we have find ways to
make sure that their choices of products
in the marketplace that there are that
we don't have challenges with
out-of-pocket costs for people but they
actually can get access especially for
treatments for chronic disease when they
have it so there are plenty of ways that
would get sick even a current system
wherein all we at the same time in the
country think about what's the most
affordable but most effective way to
provide to provide coverage in the long
term yeah and that's one of those things
where when I hear that you know on the
right they laugh and say hey premiums
continue to increase under Obamacare and
of course that's true but they've
arguably increased less quickly than
they are
their lies would have I think it's
important to fact-check that when we
hear that from the right but at the same
time if the victory is well yes it keeps
getting more expensive but not by as
much as it otherwise might have it still
feels like it's a it's a sort of Pyrrhic
victory in a way it's a victory but
we're still not fixing the overarching
problem well I mean we've been we've
been talking about fixing health care
for a long time and it is creeping up to
being moving for me a fix of our economy
to assist of our economy so it's clearly
continuing to grow on the other hand
you're right the growth has
significantly slowed and even just in
the big picture we've saved at least
half a billion dollars compared to what
we would have spent if we hadn't had the
Affordable Care Act the work we were
doing at HHS and and honestly a lot of
innovation at the state level in the
private sector as well has meant that
we're getting to care system more
efficient just as we're bringing more
people in so why would we want to stop
you know sort of that progress
everybody's been working together
because it those are related ideas you
have to have a way to pay for care but
we want everybody to have something
that's before but we spend twice as much
purple on average per person in this
country for health care as any other of
our pure nations and our return on
investment is worse and we have some of
the worst health outcomes on the planet
and in fact for the first time recently
we're starting to see some concerning
numbers about life expectancy so we
don't want to stop with takane's we want
to keep making sure that we're making
making the care system better for people
but we want to keep bringing more people
in yet the life expectancy thing is
something we've been covering and maybe
something we could we could have you
back on to talk about in the future
we've been funking with dr. Karen
DeSalvo thank you so much for talking to
us about this today great well thank you
very much for the time I really
appreciate it